SPILLING RUSSIA'S WAR IN UKRAINE
SETTING OFF FEARS OF
WORLD WAR III AFTER A MISSILE
HIT POLAND NEAR THE UKRAINIAN
BORDER KILLING TWO PEOPLE,
REPORTS INITIALLY CLAIMED IT WAS
A RUSSIAN ATTACK AND NOW THE
CONSENSUS IS THAT IT WAS LIKELY
CAUSED BY UKRAINE'S AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
PRESIDENT BITING ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE AFTER IT HAPPENED.
>> THERE IS GLENN MARY
INFORMATION TO CONTEST THAT I
DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT UNTIL WE
COMPLETELY INVESTIGATE.
AND IT'S UNLIKELY IN THE MINDS
OF THE TRAJECTORY THAT IT WAS
FIRED FROM RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: LUCKY TO AVOID
ARMAGEDDON, BUT THAT'S NOT
STOPPING JOE BIDEN FROM ASKING
CONGRESS FOR ANOTHER $37 BILLION
TO KEEP WARREN UKRAINE, AND TOP
MILITARY OFFICERS EXPECTING THE
U.S. SUPPORT TO CONTINUE.
>> RUSSIA COULD PUT AN END TO IT
RIGHT NOW, BUT THEY WON'T.
AND WE, THE UNITED STATES, UNDER
THE DIRECTION OF THE PRESIDENT
AND THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT UKRAINE
FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES TO KEEP
THEM FREE, SOVEREIGN,
INDEPENDENT WITH THEIR TERRITORY
INTACT.
>> Jesse: DANA PERINO, ARE WE
GETTING CLOSER TO WORLD WAR III?
>> Dana: NO, HOPEFULLY.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF THINGS COULD COOLER HEADS
PREVAILED, THAT'S ALWAYS GOOD.
AND IT'S NOT REALLY IN RUSSIA'S
BEST INTEREST RIGHT NOW TO
ATTACK A NATO COUNTRY, AND I
ALSO THINK OF RUSSIA WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION TO ATTACK A NATO
COUNTRY, IT WOULD NOT BE TOO
UNFORTUNATELY KILLED TWO FARMERS
IN POLAND.
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
WHOLE DIFFERENT THING.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION,
$3.7 MILLION AND THEY WANT TO
GET IT DONE AND THE LAME DUCK
IT, AND I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
DO, BECAUSE THINGS WILL CHANGE
IN JANUARY WHEN YOU HAVE A NEW
CONGRESS, BUT THE ONE THING
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES NOT DO
ENOUGH IN MY OPINION IS
EXPLAINED TO THE UNITED STATES
WHY IS IT AND OUR INTEREST TO DO
THIS.
AND IF YOU MAKE THE CASE, THEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GENEROUS, WE CARE ABOUT FREEDOM
AND OUR NATIONAL SECURITY AND
TAKE CARE OF THINGS AT HOME, BUT
YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN THAT COME
YOU CAN'T JUST TRYING TO PASS
THESE BILLS WITHOUT MORE OF AN
EXPLANATION.
>> Jesse: GREG GUTFELD.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: GREG GUTFELD HAS A
LOT OF PLANS FOR THE LAME DUCK.
ARE YOU PLANNING ON SPENDING
THAT MUCH MONEY ON UKRAINE?
>> Greg: HERE IS THE THING.
I DON'T TRUST ANYTHING COMING
OUT OF RUSSIA.
I DON'T TRUST ANYTHING OUT OF
THE UKRAINE.
I DON'T TRUST ANYTHING COMING
OUT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SORRY.
WE HAVE BEEN LIED TO ABOUT
COVID.
AFGHANISTAN.
WE HAVE BEEN LIED TO ABOUT A
RACK.
WHAT ELSE HAVE WE BEEN LIED TO?
>> Jesse: WERE LIED TO ABOUT
YOUR ROOM.
IT >> Greg: I WAS LIED TO
ABOUT MY ROOM!
BUT IT IS INTERESTING THAT WE
HAVE NOT REALLY COVER THE STORY
IN MONTHS.
AND IT'S LIKE WE GOT USED TO IT,
200,000 PEOPLE DEAD, 100
TROOPS -- 100,000 ON EACH SIDE
MAY BE MORE, AND IT'S JUST
BACKGROUND NOISE AND IT'S KIND
OF SAD, BECAUSE THERE IS A WAR
GOING ON, BUT THERE IS A WAR OF
PERSUASION AND WAR OF
PROPAGANDA, AND WHEN THAT
GENERAL SAYS FOR AS LONG AS IT
TAKES, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS IT IS NO SKIN OFF OUR
NECKS.
WE DON'T NOTICE IT.
SO IT COULD GO ON FOREVER.
AND YOU ARE SEEING ONE OF THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD GET DESTROYED.
SO IT'S A SAD STORY.
>> Jesse: JUDGE JEANINE, DO
YOU TRUST JOE BIDEN AS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO GUIDE US?
SPILLING DON'T FINISH THE
QUESTION, YOU KNOW IT'S NO
ALREADY.
HERE'S THE THING, I AGREE WITH
GREG.
I DON'T -- THIS IS ONE TIME
WHERE I HOPE THAT THEY ARE
LYING.
IF IT DID COME FROM RUSSIA OKAY,
I WANT THEM TO TELL ME THAT IT
DIDN'T, BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
TRIGGER WORLD WAR III, SO
HOPEFULLY THEY ARE LYING ABOUT
THAT IF IT DID END UP COMING
FROM RUSSIA.
PLUS $37 BILLION.
YOU ADD THAT TO $19.3 BILLION,
WHAT ARE WE BUYING?
WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING?
I DON'T LIKE IT WHEN I HEAR SAM
BANK MEN'S NAME CONNECTED TO
UKRAINE.
THERE'S TOO MUCH CASH OVER
THERE.
AND IF WE WANT TO SEND WEAPONS,
SEND WEAPONS.
DON'T SEND CASH.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
IT STINKS TO HIGH HELL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jesse: YOUR GUIDE
JOE BIDEN.
HEY, HAROLD, HOW ARE YOU DOING.
IS HE NAVIGATING THIS THING
PROPERLY?
>> Harold: I LIKED THE NIGHT
WE HAD LAST WEEK, DID YOU?
>> Judge Jeanine: TUESDAY
NIGHT.
>> Jesse: WHEN WE TOOK THE
HOUSE?
YOU LIKE THAT NIGHT.
YORTY HAD THE SENATE.
AND YOU BOUGHT IT WITH FUNNY
MONEY.
>> Harold: I COVERED THE
SPREAD.
AND I TRADE BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THEY ARE GREAT
PEOPLE WITH GREAT HISTORY.
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS SABOTAGED THE
WAY THAT HE IS GOING ABOUT THIS
INVASION INTO UKRAINE, IF WE DID
NOT ACT IN SOME WAY, IF WE DID
NOT CHALLENGE IT IN SOME WAY,
HISTORY WOULD SHOW THAT WE
PERHAPS APPROVE IT.
FURTHERMORE IN MY MIND, I DON'T
THINK THAT PUTIN WOULD'VE
STOPPED IN UKRAINE.
HE HAS GIVEN A SERIES OF
SPEECHES OVER THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS WHERE HE HAS LONG FOR
THE USSR AS OUR POLICY AND
THINKERS HELP BREAK UP MANY MEN
AND WOMEN, SOME WHOSE PARENTS,
SOME KIDS MAY BE CELEBRATING
THIS EVENING OR TOMORROW EVENING
WHOSE PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
FOUGHT TO WIN THE COLD WAR.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT EUROPEAN
SECURITY, BUT THEIR SECURITY IS
TIED TO OURS.
IF WE GET TO 37, IT WILL BE
56 BILLION, NOT AN AMERICAN
SOLDIER HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE ALL OF THAT GREAT AMERICAN
TECHNOLOGY AND WEAPONRY AT WORK
AND HAVE DONE ON-THE-JOB
TRAINING WITH UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
PUTIN UNDERESTIMATED ONE THING.
ONE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THING,
FIRST HE DID NOT REALIZE THAT
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WANTED TO
DICTATE THEIR FUTURE AND ON
THEIR LAND, NOW IS 20% OF THEIR
LAND OCCUPIED.
IF THIS 37 BILLION HELPS UKRAINE
OPERATE AND NEGOTIATE FROM A
POSITION OF STRENGTH, BECAUSE
THIS WAR HAS TO END WITH A
NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT.
56 BILLION WILL BE PENNILESS IF
WE ARE ABLE TO DEFEAT PUTIN AND
PUT RUSSIA ON A TRAJECTORY TO BE
SAFE, RELIABLE, DEPENDABLE, AND
FOR THAT MATTER, NOT A THREAT TO
THOSE IN THEIR BACKYARD.
>> Jes